Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie House of the Dragon Season 2 has been
filming new episodes and there were a couple
new scenes they released with a bunch of Easter
Eggs and references to the books so we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel I'll
be doing videos for all the episodes just like
season one just like the original Game of Thrones
series they even just released a teaser trailer
for the next Game of Thrones spin-off so I'll
address that at the end of the video too be
sure to subscribe to get everything there are
two big scenes they just released they're from
totally different episodes so I'll start with the
dragon base one first one of the big differences
in season 2 vs season 1 is that while we did get
way more large dragons than in the original Game
of Thrones series right off the bat during
season 2 because the actual Targaryen Civil
War begins the dance of the dragons starts we'll
start to see way more dragon battles in the sky
red hot Dragon on Dragon action they only briefly
touched on stuff like that in the original series
like the closest we got to dragon battles was in
Game of Thrones season 8 during the long night
episode when you have the night king fighting
Jon Snow and Daenerys on dragon back for a hot
second using the white version of viserion that
he'd raised from the dead but all those scenes
happened in the Blackness of night like it was
so dark that people complained they couldn't see
anything that happened during that episode with
clouds obscuring a lot of the action and to boot
it was super quick before they hit the ground
so you could barely see any actual Dragon vs
dragon fighting by house of the Dragon season 2
we start to see the greens versus the blacks on
their dragons fighting in broad daylight special
effects has just risen to the level where they
can start to pull that off without having to
hide it or cut around a lot of the action they
got there briefly at the end of season one if
you consider aymond and vegar killing lucerys
while he was on his dragon air ax R.I.P one of
the scenes they released is actually related to
what happened at the end of season one this
first scene though is from the aftermath of
the battle of rook's rest it's meant to be later
in the season around episode 6 or episode 7 and
remember there are only going to be eight episodes
in season two which does kind of suck that they're
cutting it short I'll explain why they did that
because part of the reason for doing that is
is because of what happens with the Battle of
Rooks rest during the scene you see aegon II's
parade pushing a car through the streets of
King's Landing with the small folk gathered
around cheering like they're treating it like
a big victory these were aegon's new banners
he's part of Allison screens that's why the
Banners are green with gold Targaryen sigils
friends
it is meant to be a Victory Parade aegon is
returning victorious in his battle against
reniro's side because the battle itself rook's
rest is a big victory for the greens zoom in
enhance on the banners too A lot of people have
asked about this you notice that the dragon
sigils on it only have two legs instead of the
traditional four-legged dragons on the red and
black Targaryen sigils from season one Ryan
Condall the showrunner said that he wanted to
explain why the Targaryen sigil changed over their
history from four-legged Dragon sigils to two legs
during the time of Daenerys in the original Game
of Thrones series much later in the timeline and
it's meant to pay off a long-running fan question
from the original series on the original series
around season 6 and season 7 Daenerys started
using their traditional Targaryen banners again
with four legs but if you look at a lot of the
merch in way before season 1 premiered all the
Targaryen banners although sigils had two legs
on them so a lot of people were like why did
they switch from two legs to four legs all of a
sudden they never really explained this during
the original series The practical reason is
because they just like the four-legged look
better Ryan Condall is doing a bit of a Dave
Filoni in the Star Wars Universe Dave fluent
he does this all the time where like he'll retcon
stuff to make it seem cooler in retrospect like no
we plant it this way the whole time and this is
the reason why because after Robert's Rebellion
all the Targaryen banners and sigils their symbols
had either been hidden or burned so later in the
timeline you started to see two-legged banners
popping up and some past examples left over
from when aegon was briefly King with two-legged
banners earlier in the timeline during House of
the Dragon when aegon iI becomes king and makes
his own green and gold banners they wanted to
differentiate them from renera's traditional
Targaryen banners and that's why they have
two legs one of the funny things about Damon and
Rhaenyra is that they're meant to be old school
traditionalist targets like they call them old
school targaryens like they had their wedding in
the old Valyrian Traditions so they adhere to the
classic old traditions they made all those snide
comments and criticisms of alicent when she put
all the banners of the faith of the seven around
replacing Targaryen sigils in the red keep s
nice to be home but I scarcely recognize it
lyrics he's a giant seven-pointed star in the main
hallway good if you ask me I'm sure once they see
aegon's gold banners with the two-legged dragons
daemon and rhaenyra will also make some other
snide comments like how dare you put two-legged
dragons on there that's so inaccurate he also
said when they were making house the dragon they
wanted to honor what Daenerys did when she was
picking it when she was coming to power with the
four-legged banners by saying that that had always
been the Targaryen tradition to have four-legged
banners the real answer though is that the Game
of Thrones people at HBO just changed their minds
between the beginning of the season and later in
season six and season seven like you know what
we think that four legs is better but to address
the dead dragon in the room on the cart there
parading the dead dragon through the city zooming
in hands you can see the spikes sticking out of
the head it's melee's rhaenys Dragon R.I.P Meleys
during the Battle of rook's rest she fights aegon
and his Dragon Sunfyre in the sky and even though
they both die R.I.P they wound aegon so badly
that he winds up wishing that he died like dying
would have been a mercy and it's meant to pay off
Helaena targaryen's Dragon Dream from season one
where she says the last ring has no legs that was
a dragon dream about aegon II losing the ability
to walk the last ring has Rhaeny's basically winds
up breaking his back rook's rest is the seat of
how Staunton here who declared for Rhaenyra it's
on the edge of Blackwater Bay near Dragonstone but
like I said it's meant to be a big victory for
the greens and part of the reason why they're
cutting season two shorter is because they want
to end the season in the aftermath of the battle
of rook's rest with a victory for the greens as a
way to book in the major WTF moment victory that
renira's side has at the beginning of the season
so it's one of those situations during the season
where they start with a victory for the blacks
but a big loss for the blacks so like both sides
the greens and the blacks win some and they both
lose some during the season in the other major
scene that they released that they were filming
is the aftermath of that Mega WTF victory for the
blacks at the beginning of the Season although
I wouldn't call it a victory it's more of like
a scorched Earth really bad WTF kind of Victory
because it's all about blood and cheese and even
Rhaenyra herself has absolutely nothing to do
with it in the scene you see Alicent and Helaena
Targaryen riding in a cart with a funeral session
through the city with a casket on this cart and
it's meant to be a very sad scene in contrast
to the Victory Parade which happens at the end
of the season that I just talked about in the
funeral scene there's a town crier yelling out
Behold The Works of renera the cruel blaming
Rhaenyra for the death of Helaena and aegon's
oldest son Prince Jaehaerys he'd been named after
their great-grandfather King Jaehaerys surprise
them calling renira the cruel was meant to be a
book referenced during her storyline the people
of King's Landing start to refer to her as maegor
with tits maegor had been called maegor the cruel
so the greens are blaming renera for the death of
aegon and Helaena's son but what really happened
is that Daemon was the one that pulled this off
he was responsible for everything and was meant
to be revenge for the death of lucerys at the end
of season one originally Daemon's plan was to have
missaria acting on his behalf higher assassins
to kill one of aegon's children in Revenge for
the death of lucerys declaring an eye for an eye
a sun for a son another reference to eamonn's one
eye Daemon didn't care which son Mysterio wound
up killing Miss area hires blood and cheese they
sneak into the red keep and force Helaena to
choose which of her children they would kill so
it winds up being this really brutal moment really
WTF like I said and even rhaenira is horrified
when she finds out what Daemon did like how dare
you go above my head to do something like this
I never authorized you to do this that was a big
thing during season one with her trying to prevent
Daemon from going off the chain like just chill
for a second we don't want to burn the kingdom
to the ground and Daemon almost winds up choking
her out because she doesn't want to go immediately
to war even though she is bitter about the death
of lucerus a big theme during season one and it
continues through the entire conflict like all the
seasons is that both Alicent Rhaenyra never wanted
to have a war but all the people around them like
the green Council on Alicent's side Rhaenyra's
black Council on her side all those people go
way overboard pushing things further and further
out of control which leads to the near utter
destruction like scorched Earth policy in King's
Landing which is something Rhaenyra references
during season one where she says she doesn't
want to rule over the ashes they also ironically
wind up having Daenerys say something similar on
the original Game of Thrones series later in the
timeline and just like later in the timeline with
Daenerys it leads to a pretty much scorched earth
policy around King's Landing that's why things end
badly for both sides even though eventually there
is an ultimate cictor the whole idea during the
series is in the dance of the Dragons even though
there has to be at least one victor at some point
both sides wind up losing really the only thing
that could tear down the house of the Dragon
itself in related Game of Thrones news
they just announced the tales of Duncan
egg's spin-off Series right now they're just
calling it The Hedge Knight they'll have some
other title once it eventually makes it to
episodes but they did confirm that it will
get a full order of episodes it's going to run
a little bit shorter than the normal 10 episode
run though they just released a teaser trailer
for that I did a much bigger video for it so
I'll link it at the end of this but it will be
a couple more years before it makes it to air
it's meant to be the beginning of like the many
many spin-offs and prequels are doing for Game
of Thrones eventually we'll see all of them it's
just the Hedge Knight one will be the next one
we see after House of the dragon and they might
run concurrently for a season or two click here
to watch the trailer for that my full video and
click here for all my house the Dragon season 2
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!